Bonjour à toutes et à tous, et bienvenue dans
ce nouvel épisode d' "Un Zeste pour la planète"!
Si je vous dis "industries chimiques", j'imagine que
vous pensez à plein de polluants super flippants, à
des rivières vert fluo, des rats à trois têtes voire
des tortues balèzes en arts martiaux, mais vous
vous dites aussi que l'industrie chimique, on en a
besoin au quotidien pour créer des médicaments, des
polymères, des sacs plastiques... Euh, non, ça bof...
Bref c'est compliqué de s'en passer. Heureusement,
il existe maintenant une chimie d'un genre nouveau,
qu'on appelle verte : les chercheurs ont mis au
point des technologies qui permettent de créer
des produits synthétiques, qui non seulement
n'engendrent plus de nouvelle pollution, mais en
plus, font disparaître la pollution déjà existante.
Ne pas polluer davantage, c'est bien, mais dépolluer notre planète, c'est mieux, parce que
ça fait des décennies que notre industrie lache
dans la nature des métaux lourds, qui contaminent
les sols mais aussi les rivières, ou encore
les nappes phréatiques. Pour les détoxifier
de manière écolo, les chercheurs du CNRS proposent
d'utiliser des plantes. Vous savez, ce truc qu'on
tue quand on pollue. Des jardins filtrants
permettent en effet de purifier les eaux et
sédiments chargés de déchets. Pour découvrir ça,
suivez-nous dans la bioferme phytorestore.
Ici, on peut purifier plusieurs types de boues, comme
celle de la fosse septique ou encore les boues
industrielles contenant pléthore de métaux
lourds. Ou "heavy metals" comme disent nos
amis anglophones. Alors, non non, rien à voir avec la
musique : ici "lourds" signifie surtout "toxiques". Tout
ça grâce aux racines des plantes, qui ont plus d'un
tour dans leur sac. Pour comprendre comment elles
réagissent face aux différents métaux lourds,
il va nous falloir une technologie de pointe.
les scientifiques doivent d'abord prélever des
échantillons, puis on les congèle en vitesse pour
figer les éléments qui s'y trouvent, et enfin on
envoie la plante se faire scruter sous un rayon X
pour révéler comment les racines réagissent
face aux métaux à l'échelle microscopique.
On constate alors que quand le taux de cuivre est
bas, il est perçu comme un micro-nutriment : la
plante va donc le capter à l'intérieur de sa
sève brute et l'envoyer vers ses feuilles pour
en nourrir la croissance. On a donc affaire
à des plantes qui mangent du métal, ce qui
pour le coup est très "METAAAAL", mais quand la
plante est dans un endroit trop pollué, elle
va résister à la pollution en faisant appel à
ses mycorhizes. Les mycorhizes sont des champignons
filamenteux qui se forment sur les racines. Ils ont
plein de fonctions. Par exemple, ils augmentent le
réseau des racines ce qui permet à la plante de
croître en profitant de plus de nutriments.
Ce qui intéresse les scientifiques, c'est qu'ils peuvent
aussi servir de pièges pour les métaux lourds,
quand ils sont présents en trop grande quantité
au goût de la plante. Les mycorhizes vont alors
précipiter le métal et l'immobiliser pour créer
une bulle saine autour des racines principales.
Dans cette ferme dépolluante, une fois que lesmétaux ont été concentrés et ont percolé à
la base des bassins, ils sont envoyés dans desfiltres de piégeage. L'élément clé de ces filtres
100% naturels, ce sont les tourbes. Mais attention, toutes les tourbes ne se ressemblent pas ! Il en
existe différents types, qui vont plus ou moinsbien matcher avec les métaux que l'on chercheà éliminer.
-Alors, Tourbe de sphaigne, t'as du lourd
sur Tinder ?
-Pfff, oh bah, là non, hein.Ah ! Attends...
Bastos du 82... Il a l'air d'avoir du plomb dans la tête...J'adore ! Et toi ?
-Horf, bah moi... Next, next... Ah,Mercure
du 69 ! Ouh, celui-là fait monter la température !
-Etça marche très bien ! A la fin du piégeage, 98% des
métaux sont tombés dans les mailles du filet. Cesméthodes écolo présentent un autre avantage non
négligeable : elles sont économiques ! Aujourd'hui, enFrance, pour dépolluer une tonne de boue industrielle,
il faut débourser 300 euros. Un prix prohibitifpour tous les pays en voie de développement, qui ne
peuvent tout simplement pas traiter leurs déchets.
Alors qu'avec les méthodes de la bioferme, le prix
de l'assainissement des boues industrielles tombeà 2 euros la tonne. De quoi donner les moyens aux
pays les plus défavorisés de ne pas être aussiles plus pollués, et de convaincre au passage les
pays les plus riches que ça vaut le coup, puisquevisiblement l'argument écologique ne suffit pas.
Ohoho ! Oh oui, c'est parfait, non mais même à 2 euros latonne, avec toutes les saletés qui traînent un
peu partout dans le monde, ouh, ça va chiffrersévère !
Mais revenons à notre belle vieille
France. Ah, la France, ses plaines, ses montagnes, sesmines de zinc abandonnées où plus rien ne pousse à
cause de la pollution ! Nos chercheurs n'allaientpas laisser ce problème sans solution. Il est
désormais possible, avec des méthodes toutesdouces, de dépolluer les sols et les eaux des
anciens sites d'extraction minière, qui deviendrontpeut-être bientôt de beaux espaces boisés, dont les
enfants pourront déguster la délicieuse boue.
Évidemment ces sols ultra-pollués ne laissent
aucune chance aux plantes que nous avons vu tout
à l'heure et à leurs amis les mycorhizes. Pour ces
zones, il existe des super-plantes, capables desurvivre à la présence de très fortes teneurs en
métaux. Mais ce n'est pas tout : elles sont égalementcapables de les capter pour les envoyer dans leurs
feuilles ! Je vous présente la très jolie et trèscostaude anthyllide vulnéraire. Sur cette ancienne
mine d'extraction de zinc, à Saint-Laurent-le-Minier, la chimiste Claude Grison la cultive
et la chouchoute. La scientifique estime qu'aveccette plante, le site sera dépollué en moins de
50 ans ! Et même si ça prend du temps, ça vautle coup !
-Oh, mais qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fiche !
Personne n'y va, là-bas !
-Attends, t'as pas une maisond'architecte à 2 km du site, toi ?
-Bah, si, pourquoi?
-Ah ! Ben parce que les sols sont pollués, du coup lesplantes ne poussent plus, et comme les plantes ne
poussent plus, les vents peuvent emporter de plusen plus de morceaux du sol pollué, qui t'arrive
en plein dans la tronche quand le vent souffleau nord-ouest ; là, voilà, pile sur ton jacuzzi.
-Ah non hein ! Pas mon jacuzzi hein ! Bon, c'est à qui qu'il faut donnerdu pognon, là, pour les plantes qui bouffent le
mercure tout ça, hein ?
C'est bien beau, tout ça, mais une
plante dépolluante dont les feuilles sont donc
polluées, c'est comme une relation toxique : il fautvite s'en débarrasser, parce que si on ne fait
rien, au bout d'un moment, elle va mourir, pourrir et
repolluer ton sol. Il faut agir vite ! Heureusement,
il existe l'écocatalyse, un procédé génial quipermet de valoriser ces déchets végétaux riches
en métaux lourds. Les particules métalliques à
l'intérieur des plantes polluées sont récupérées
et avec les métaux extraits, on peut faire descatalyseurs. Les catalyseurs sont des produits
essentiels en chimie. Ils servent à accélérer uneréaction pour construire une molécule complexe à
base d'éléments plus sommaires. Avec ces catalyseurs, on peut synthétiser des centaines de produits et
rentrer de plein pied dans la chimie verte :la chimie qui propose des produits à la
fois synthétiques et éco-responsables ; la chimiequi crée du neuf avec du vieux, qui dépollue les
deux millions de sites qu'on à bousillés rienqu'en Europe en exploitant les mines de métal.
Une chimie verte, qui pollue pas l'herbe,
elle attrape les métaux lourd et distribue dans l'amour,
ces messieurs me disent, mettez-la en terre, trempez-la dans l'eau, elle fera pas de dégâts, c'est bon !